good morning millennials
welcome back to the show stand
Friday Friday gotta get down on strategy
everybody's looking forward to the
weekend weekend Friday Friday getting
down on Friday there's something a
little extra special about a Friday
after a week with a holiday do you know
what I mean it's like last week we
coasted this week we're back to reality
yeah this week was earned I thought you
were gonna say a Friday after a verdict
well that too I mean we are going to get
into it you guys Jackie heard your
please she watched the doc I watched the
doc just in time for the verdict to drop
just in time and so I have thoughts and
I also have a lot of questions that I'm
hoping you can answer because you watch
the trial yeah but I have the necessary
information now so I'm very glad for the
verdict that yeah it was crazy that's
our first story
um but that's kind of the name on
everyone's lips murder and not just any
Murdock turdy Lou murder today
I like mine better
yeah
[Music]
wow that was kind of like amazing
like wow wow it's a power of turtle it's
the power of attorney Luke compels you
um wait I just wanted to say I remember
like a few I think maybe in December you
were saying how like sometimes when you
go and look for the stories like it
really puts you in a funk because like
there's so much terrible news out there
and I have to tell you I know you had a
really busy morning so I was like
sending you stories and I went on
Twitter and I saw such a disturbing
video I cannot go on Twitter like it's
so but yeah there are so many disturbing
videos on Twitter that I see every
single day that are so disturbing that
you you will never hear about they don't
like really get they're not in the news
what did you see this NFL player was
sentenced to six months in prison for
um beating his wife in front of their
child and she had like a ring camera and
so I was like what is this video and I
don't even know why I watched it but
like it was he threw her literally at
the TV like it was so I saw that one and
the baby is in that little uh jumping
thing yeah yeah yeah oh my God and like
now my day's ruined yeah um I saw one
this week that I only saw on Twitter of
a man literally standing behind a
homeless man I think it's insane I saw
this
he's being filmed the whole time by some
people just a little bit away he's like
futzing with a gun the whole time trying
to load it and he executes the man in
broad daylight in the middle of the
street while people look on and just
film it they don't like shout to the guy
like hey they don't call the police look
out yeah they don't call the police they
don't get oh God forbid they get the
[__] up and and do something right oh
man I saw that video too no and uh this
information actually that video is
actually that episode of Black Mirror
you know that episode where someone
commits a crime in their life and then
their punishment is that they have to
relive like the same day over and over
again where terrible things happen to
them and people just follow them it
becomes like a museum like they're at
the zoo pretty much like they're in the
zoo and people like tourists come and
just film them all day while all these
terrible things happen to them Black
Mirror was
such a crazy show I know like I mean I
won't get into you know stop turdy Lou
it's Friday come on
okay I won't bring it up um but if you
know you know
um that was just like a crazy time that
Black Mirror like era
yeah so many episodes of the episodes
are just so pertinent that one in
particular I don't know what it's called
or anything but it was just like you
don't know what's happening till the end
so I I also just spoiled it
um but it's the person's punishment for
whatever crime they committed they every
day like they wake up they get like
Amnesia the night before they have to
live the same day over and over again
where they're so confused horrible
things are happening to them and people
just come and visit and tourists come
and just take videos of them the whole
time they're like what the [__] is this
um
well that's a great like negative note
to start the show on let's let's turn
um it's Friday you have any plans for
the weekend
you know I do some some light plans
nothing it's like set in stone to some
ideas
I'm ideating for the weekend what about
you
nothing I mean Ben got back at like one
in the morning last night from LA and
then this morning he was up at six to go
to Boston and he gets back tonight so
like I just know he's not going to want
to do anything so my weekends are in
thanks Ben
that doesn't sound like Ben you know Ben
has like actually really good um social
battery and physical battery yeah it's
where we we differ the most
I think he'll rally he probably just
wants like a few hours to chill but then
he'll probably want to go do something
tonight
I don't know it's like so soon you know
you don't know if you're ready I don't
know if I'm ready no not at all
I understand are you happy to be whole
are you happy that he's home or are you
not happy no I am happy except like I
had just drifted into like a gorgeous
sleep when he woke up
um he could have stayed at a hotel no I
know and that was so wrong and then I
was like oh I hear him I should say Hi
and then he was so tired he passed out
I'm like [__] I'm literally just
sitting here that's so wrong it was it
was wrong on a multitude of levels he's
wrong for that wrong he didn't give a
rip when Zach wakes me up out of like a
real sleep
jail
jail time
Jail jail time should be served
I always say there's a special place in
hell for people who like don't and not
that bad nurse act do this like dude who
don't respect other people's sleep but
if you don't do everything in your power
not to wake up the person like in the
room with you like that's not cool
yeah like girls in Camp like when you
were like taking a nap during rest hour
and they were just like being loud like
I'm resting that's hard it's a communal
space no but like how's it go play
outside like have some respect oh wow
you're running you're turning into the
teacher of the show go play outside come
on seriously like I'm napping here some
respect for my nap it's it's rest hour I
feel like Camp is like really you can
always tell when someone went to Camp
because Camp is where you really learn
to like play and live with others you
know on a on a small and a big scale
yeah like sharing a shower sharing
living facilities like so how can you
tell when someone went to Camp when they
don't respect your nap time
but you said some of the campers didn't
but that's where they learned it's
because it was there for a summer it's
where they learned
yeah they'll learn today I miss camp
like I would literally do anything to be
15 again like getting ready for the for
the summer honestly you know is this
sort of conversation that inspired the
first Camp toast like just missing Camp
wanting to write back saying why can't
we go to camp at no I mean by the way we
can and kemptos was amazing but it was
different there's really nothing like
being young like having your parents pay
for your Camp you know I can't toast you
paid for it like no not even that having
the whole summer off like you're lucky
if you could get a weekend now but you
have no responsibilities no ties you're
untethered in two months it wasn't even
long enough no I know and just like
having really no worries in the world
like just being able to be free be
outside run around make friends fall in
love like it was really ugh Camp is so
special I could literally I could start
the morning camp like a new podcast all
about camp and all the things I learned
all my fun experiences
people would love that I just loved camp
and like this how come every
conversation we're having is taking a
depressing turn oh man I don't know why
we're being so negative today we're just
depressed I know I
don't know it's Friday we gotta buck up
maybe because I ate a bagel before this
and the carbs are weighing me down you
know I usually just have a yogurt maybe
a macro bar you're kind of like the
jurors who ate lasagna I'm the shirt and
now I'm just like guilty literally
but I don't know why I'm being negative
I actually got to sleep in because you
had some like hairy things to do today
before the show so I got like an extra
45 minutes of sleep I look gorgeous I'm
feeling good it's a little hot in here
but like whatever
um I don't know why I'm like kind of
being like a negative Queen
I don't know let's lean into it we've
been so positive you're so bright we've
been so annoying so disgusting so not us
just so excited if you want to leave
yeah let's go back to like hating
everyone and everything okay what's next
what else are you hating uh well it's
actually part of our Second Story we're
going to recap the story that doesn't
exist which is the Haley Bieber Selena
Gomez drama and I have some people I
really [__] hate in that story and
it's not who you guys might think
it's not any of the major parties
involved can't wait to hear actually I
think I know it's it's exactly who we
think and it's the people that you've
always hated and that's the Julina
stands not even the Julian Assange like
just anyone who's really getting
themselves all bent out of [__]
shape about three people who don't know
who they are who don't care who they are
and who literally like none of them have
done anything this is just like a story
created out of thin air and so everyone
yesterday was like can't believe you're
not talking about Jelena Haley Kylie you
guys are so toxic all those people are
deeply unwell
what the hell would we talk about
nothing has happened on not not Selena
not Haley not Kylie has even spoken or
done anything since we last reported the
story no and even when we reported this
story our assessment was that nothing
actually happened like these were two
isolated videos that really have nothing
to do with each other and the only
person Who's acting out is Selena by
like commenting on all these like Victor
mentality encouraging encouraging and
encouraging it but like Kylie and the
crew like literally didn't do anything
other than post their own stuff so we we
report on that initial nothingness right
and the nothingness that is spurned
after
people like it's crazy because there is
so much going on in the world you know
like there's so many things to get up in
arms about 100 to take up the cause for
and you would think that there was world
peace and complete quiet 100 based on
how people are reaching and looking for
something to complain about no I
completely agree
um so it's the it's the commoners who
have made this story
literally exist it's we'll talk about it
that's our Second Story let's just dive
in you know let's just dive in to the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you embark on this Friday and
today's episode is sponsored by State
Farm the State Farm personal price plan
helps you create a plan that gives you
options so you get an affordable price
and it comes with a lot of benefits like
the coverage you want a policy that
helps cover what's important to you and
an affordable price just for you because
after all life is just better when you
can personalize your experience and you
know I love that that's kind of the
motto of State Farm because that's kind
of the motto of the toast we're always
saying everything is so personal
everything should be personal comedy
food poetry life and insurance you know
personalization means that you have the
power to choose what you want to include
and leave out
it just feels better that way and why
shouldn't insurance work like that too
that's what the State Farm personal
price plan is all about you can choose
to include options like bundling your
home and auto policies which means
you'll get the coverage you want at an
affordable price just for you and in the
end you have a policy that gives what
you want doesn't that feel better I mean
even Jax and I were so D we're so
similar we're so similar but our
insurance plans are so different you're
a homeowner I'm not we're all different
and so our insurance policies should be
as well
like a good neighbor
State Farm is there call or go to
statefarm.com today to create your State
Farm personal price plan prices vary by
state option selected by customer
availability and eligibility may vary
thank you State Farms for sponsoring
today's very special Friday edition
episode of the toast and like a good
neighbor State Farm is always there
always there
thank you Claudia what can I say except
yeah well
um
are you ready for our first big story
the wheels of Justice have turned wow
I'm feeling really singing today and
pretty quick for the wheels of Justice
which are notoriously slow to turn
except if you look at it from the big
picture of the Justice Wheels on the
Murdoch family we're slow to turn yes
but in terms of this case you're right
the jury returned in two hours and 50
minutes and the sentencing was done the
next morning because last night they
came back I was like I thought we were
going to wait even for the jury till the
morning and the guy said okay guilty and
then he said we will do sentencing at a
later date and the prosecution said uh
we'll be ready at 9 30 a.m tomorrow
morning preparedness
Alec murder has been sentenced to life
in prison for the murders of his wife
and son signaling the death knell of a
once revered Southern Dynasty family and
its disgraced patriarch Murdoch was
found guilty yesterday of murdering
Maggie and Paul at the family's hunting
lodge in June 2021 he faces uh he faced
between 30 years and life in prison and
he got two life sentences in what came
down this morning Theo snoring is just
too sweet for this world do you hear it
that's not he's not snoring I don't know
what this is Jackie I'm sitting right
next to him he's not snoring
okay he stopped no there's no we can
start again
you really don't hear it if Jackie take
your headphone off
I didn't hear that oh that was a breath
how the [__] do you hear that [__] I
don't know that's why I thought it was
so loud that I'm hearing it that's weird
no one else is gonna hear it
damn that's crazy that is crazy what's
all so crazy is this whole case so yeah
I watched the murder murders on Netflix
also what's crazy that their last name
is murder I know everyone keeps saying
Murdoch but like it's not it's murder
and that's another way of saying murder
yeah no like there people are saying it
all different ways and I think kind of
any way goes depending on where you're
from so murder but murder murder
I wanna be
a murderer
so the documentary was really good I
really enjoyed having all of the
information a lot of the backstory about
the family in general and then how we
got to this place but my question is was
it established during the trial what was
his motive for killing his wife and son
so that was I think something that they
struggled with but
um
there's a lot of different theories and
I think the kind of most commonly
believed theory is that you know this
family was getting away with literal
murder for years and Corruption and
financial crimes and it really wasn't
until Paul was so messy with the Mallory
beach murder that things started to
slowly unravel and people started to
look into the family and whisper in town
and I think there was a lot of rage from
Alec that his son being a [__] and like
a drug idiot was gonna Maybe
tumble this whole you know House of
Cards down there's also the working
Theory but I it's important to know that
Paul was shot first
thus thus making everyone believed like
he was the intended victim
yeah
um but you know Alec did request that
his wife Maggie come to the house that
night him and Maggie at the time were
not living together she was staying at
the beach house it's believed that she
had uncovered something I mean I don't
know what the [__] she couldn't have
known she knew that they were like
killing people all all this time and
stealing money but that she hadn't she
was planning on leaving him and he you
know they had to literally kill their
housekeeper just to get money like they
were not in a good Financial place and
divorce is very expensive so that could
have been another motive although she
was shot second so I don't really know
if that theory works for me I do believe
it it was uh meant for Paul
but then why did he want Maggie it was
pre-planned like he told Maggie like
come to the house she was like maybe
Paul was trying to step in between them
and he shot him so that's also he is
like a drug addict and was on and off
like abusing and withdrawing and uh
detoxing as Morgan said so maybe he like
his actions don't make sense so I know
that there is a Netflix documentary and
an HBO Max documentary and the Netflix
one is more popular but from what I've
heard and my general takeaway from the
Netflix documentary was I really
appreciated the backstory especially
them giving a voice to Mallory Beach
because her murder was so sad and so
corrupt and really they never got
Justice
um however as it pertains to the trial I
think a lot more of the more pertinent
like footage and you know Witnesses and
and evidence is in the HBO documentary
so
if you're really interested I would
recommend that okay
um
yeah the also the interesting thing and
why I thought they really weren't gonna
convict him was a few things one this is
a jury of his peers and it's very
possible like a lot of people are still
very intimidated by the Murdoch name and
they don't want to make themselves a
Target
um and they could have just like swept
this under the rug but it's clear that
like people in this town and the low
country are just like sick of this like
they don't want to keep living with
these people
um and them delivering a a verdict in
three hours is crazy less than three
hours especially when you think about
you know they don't immediately sit down
and start talking they have to put them
in the room and give them all the
evidence and all the indictments like
that [__] takes time so I would say they
probably started talking maybe like an
hour later they had 45 minutes and they
reached the unanimous guilty verdict
that's crazy yeah I think also
um
the it was clear through the trial like
these people don't have any money he's
not a working lawyer anymore this has
become the biggest case in the country
like all the other small things that
happened before didn't Garner any
attention so it does get swept under the
arc like you can sweep this under the
rug right so they don't have the power
influence and money that they once did
so it would be shocking if the jury were
still afraid afraid because like what
power does this man have now no the jury
they're good Southern you know family
people they don't want this [__] in
their town no they don't and like you're
murdering our sons and daughters get the
[__] out of here get the [__] out of
here so I I was shocked also because you
know the most damning evidence they had
um so when when police show up after
Alec calls them and he quotes fun finds
the bodies what he says is that he was
out visiting his parents he just got
home and
he called the police and what he said
was I
you know I checked their pulses and I
got a gun because I thought somebody
might be might be here whatever then as
it turns out through unlocking Paul's
phone is that the dad was on the
property not only an hour before but
minutes before because they're at the
kennel Paul is taking a video of the
dogs and you hear Alec and Maggie in the
background so he was literally there I
think it's like six minutes before Paul
was shot first
um so he lied and he does admit to lying
just saying you know he's just said it
and then he ran with it and he doesn't
know why and he was so emotional yada
yada
um but there is no
murder weapon the gun like mysteriously
disappeared you know
um
and there is no like extremely clear
motive there's like a million hypotheses
where I this term man but there's no
clear
so I was just really shocked because the
most damning thing is the video and
that's really bad like he was at the
house at the time of the murder that's
really bad but also the fact that there
was like backsplash on his shirt no it
wasn't that it was that the clothes he
was wearing
when the police showed up were different
than the clothes in the video that was
taken one hour prior
but then forensic evidence was done on
the shirt
the shirt that he was wearing
when he got picked up
maybe yeah maybe and that shirt had like
stuff on it that would like the blowback
from a rifle well he had said that he
went to check the pulse and what the uh
what the uh prosecution said which is a
really good call is you know Paul was
shot in the head
your brains when you get shot in the
head are
Smithereens they're laying on the floor
so no offense what rational person is
going to check the pulse of a person
whose head is legitimately been exploded
onto the floor which is a great Point as
well
yeah
like when Nancy Grace went to lunch she
had an expert on and the expert is on
you know I've been to crime scenes where
people have been shot in the head you
have to scoop up their brains with a
ladle that was like JFK right Jackie so
what the [__] is checking someone's
pulse going to do [__]
true
um and you know Buster was there third
row Buster yeah there's also a working
theory that buster did and Alec is
covering up for him but like Alec would
never throw himself in front of the fire
for anyone else no or they did it
together because if I'm Buster I'm
[__] pissed at my dad killed my mom
my brother yeah but like Buster's also
[__] diabolical like this is a family
you can't use that logic and this is a
family of
deep unwellness yeah no we can't even
get into their mindsets right right
and that's why I also think there might
have been things that Paul and Maggie
discovered or knew
um that we don't even know no I think
there is so much that we don't know and
will never know about what went on on in
that family yeah I think but what we
know for certain is that he killed those
two yeah and then also like the suicide
attempt so [__] weird with the cousin
that to me like was like
it was I understood his plan there it
was like to get this guy to come and
look like he's about to kill him instead
Alec kills this guy and now this guy
looks like he's guilty for all the
murders right right no
they were like so
precise in all their criminal activity
for years and then it was like after the
Mallory Beach thing like everything
started to unravel and even the way that
Alec handled that fake suicide and
writing checks like he was so messy
um
that he had to be convicted like this
wasn't they were probably messy all
along but yeah that would have looked
into it once you start looking you see
even they started looking into Stephen
Smith yeah and it's and it's officer all
over the bust yourself over it you look
into Mallory Beach like they're all over
it the housekeeper oh my God like the
housekeeper nobody looked yeah nobody
likes they were all being paid not to a
hundred percent
Buster is apparently going back to law
school
he was kicked out for plagiarism I don't
know I mean what the [__] else is he
gonna do he's only one now yeah he's got
a girlfriend which is the most shocking
part of this whole thing not only
because he's one of the ugliest
[__] I've ever seen in my
entire [__] life but also because
he's literally part of a family of
murderers like
yeah that's how you no and he might be
one himself
Stephen Smith yeah that was excuse me oh
my God such a tragedy
horrible I hope that someone was saying
I think in our family chat I hope they
open up the case into Stephen Smith
again
yeah I mean when you learned about all
the people they were you know allegedly
responsible for murdering to they get
worse and worse like Stephen Smith this
like lovely fun everyone loved him young
guy his whole life ahead of him same
with Mallory a sweetheart who was adored
by her parents and her boyfriend Gloria
this lovely old woman who was so loyal
to the family like every single one
these are [__] evil people and even
before the murder the way that he was
stealing from poor people from victims
from the vulnerable that's [__] evil
that's what evil people do and I know
it's like well you you could be a thief
but you're not going to be a murderer I
don't know there's something inherently
[__] evil about stealing from the
people you're supposed to protect
yeah and I don't see the jump from that
to murder is that crazy honestly no it's
uh to me it seems like a an escalating
scale right like a natural progression
if if nothing you've ever done has ever
been
have there ever been consequences for
right and on trial Alec did admit to
those financial crimes and I do believe
he still has to stand trial for those
yeah there's like another 70 years of
jail time that he's up for with right
his financial crimes but he's serving
two life sentences who will be in jail
for life he will be in jail for life I
mean a lot of people are not convinced
that this man will actually be in prison
for the rest of his life because he is
this like shady ass lawyer and he's
gonna work you know appeal he even
requested a mistrial the second the
verdict was
was called
um
they think he's like this slimy lawyer
like there's all these different legal
loopholes that he can you know try and
work
I I don't believe that I think it's all
caught up to him now I just think people
are so afraid because they got away with
it for so long like this is like it's
not possible that he's actually you know
they took down the Murdoch Dynasty yeah
unless I'm just not I don't know in what
ways they were so influential in the
past you know is he like the Jeffrey
Epstein of the South where he has all
these secrets about powerful people and
you know
they want to protect him or just or was
it in the past he was just like paying
you know cops and everyone was sort of
on his payroll whether legitimately or
illegitimately and so you know but the
money's run out so so yes so have the
favors so has the influence and like
where are the consequences for all the
people who whose job it was to be you
know law enforcers and who all looked
the other way all the sheriffs and the
deputies and everyone who hid their
extensive you know wrongdoings where are
the consequences for those people where
are the consequences for like the DPL or
whatever it is the not the nature
Department of Law who didn't even call
Mallory Beach's parents to tell them
right to tell them that she was missing
I don't even know if they ever called
them they didn't know that she was found
she was only even found by Good
Samaritan boaters yep it's as if they
were all looking
but not right like looking the wrong way
yeah like wanting to look like they were
looking because at first I'm like wow
they got all these helicopters there's
20 divers like this is a whole thing but
but how can you convince all these
random people to like try and not find
the body no I know but you're right like
they're it's and by the way this is only
Mallory Beach I'm sure there's even more
infractions when it comes to Steven
Smith and Gloria but like what
where are the consequences for all the
people who made this possible like of
course it's a chain of command and
starting at the top is great but like
there's this town is riddled with
corruption when it comes to law
enforcement yeah so where are the
consequences for that I don't know and
what's sled I meant to Google I don't
know that was so interesting from the
documentary I'm like what the [__] is
this agency
South Carolina law enforcement division
okay oh okay so like the whole thing
that's like NYPD oh oh yeah yeah oh yeah
right yeah okay that makes sense
glad we buttoned that up I'm glad that
the verdict was what it was they did um
while Alec was being walked out after
delivering the guilty verdict they did
Pan to the jury and everyone was
freaking out like oh my God they
accidentally panned to the jury I'm
pretty sure that's not what happened
because about six jury seats were empty
meaning I I think they were given the
choice to leave if they wanted to
protect their identities and stay if
they didn't care
um because half the jury was missing so
I don't think everyone's like oh my God
it was an accident they never they never
follow Alec out of the courtroom because
he walks past the jury to go back to
prison
um they just let him go the camera angle
doesn't go but yet last night after it
was all over it did follow him I don't
think you know this is not something
they take lightly your identity
protection I think people chose to stay
and people chose to leave yeah once
you're already gave an interview to GMA
oh what did they say he said he was a
good liar but not good enough
um no those people in the South they
don't [__] around two hours
yeah
this is It's a good day for justice I
feel like we're always reporting on the
justice system failing even though this
whole [__] story
is an exercise in the failure of the
justice system how they were able to get
away with this and it's so long even
though this instance is technically
Justice for Maggie and Paul like it's
Justice for Mallory and Stephen and
people who like were just railroaded by
this family for so many years right
what's also really interesting that I
saw something point out on Tick Tock is
that when Paul was on trial for Mallory
Beach
um he obviously never completed that
trial because he was killed by his
father but he was represented by those
two lawyers who were the two lawyers
representing
Alec this week or this month so how can
two lawyers represent a guy who's on
trial for the murder of their former
client
Paul well they must really believe he
didn't do it isn't that a conflict of
interest no it actually sounds like all
the same interests and that he's the fit
they're the family lawyer no I know but
it's just it's weird
no but like individual lawyers
especially for the defense
you can really have anyone you want it's
like the government officials who have
to recuse themselves if there's a
conflict
I think it's all lawyers if there's a
like it's part of like your oath as a
lawyer
but what could a conflict be
I don't know
it's definitely a little confusing
yeah but if they think that like that
you're defending him they don't think
that he did it so like he's you know
being Mis accused of killing this their
other client who they also deeply care
about like the Injustice is abound I
think it's I think it's a conflict
like who is being
injusticed by that
Paul
right
yeah
you know what else was really
interesting that Nancy Grace pointed out
she so was
there's so much we don't know because
why the [__] wasn't Maggie Murdoch's
family anywhere to be seen this entire
month they did not show up in court to
support like nothing maybe they don't
want to be so they don't want to be in
the press and they don't want to be
associated with the name maybe no one
has figured out that they're like murder
relatives and they just want a quiet
life I know but like your family member
is murdered and the murderer is on trial
like but but maybe they were like
present or just didn't like identify
themselves
Nancy said they were not there
and Nancy knows who everyone is
maybe they're old and they couldn't go
maybe I'm just saying like that's it's
definitely bizarre it's definitely
bizarre but I would understand like not
wanting to be a part of this no of
course
but I think your desire for justice for
your loved one trumps
your desire to not be in the spotlight
yeah
Reba said it best don't trust yourself
to no Backwoods Southern lawyer damn and
also it's like maybe if she had like a
close friend or something wouldn't they
know what was going on with her that
they testify to that a sister yeah
mother there was a few people who
testified for Maggie like friends
what did they say well they said one of
them was the one who said that uh Paul's
nickname was Little detective because he
was always finding stuff out and he was
the one who probably uncovered something
about Alec he was one who found a bag of
drugs taped under the coffee table right
right
but it was it was definitely a very
bizarre trial
you know he didn't cry when he was
convicted he didn't cry when he got a
life sentence but he gets on the stand
and he's an actor you know this guy's a
lawyer for 30 years you can't forget
that acting so much snot coming out of
his nose God forbid you just wipe it on
your [__] sleeve a juror actually
passed him a tissue because it's like oh
sir like we don't need to look at this
so it was all just so calculated
yeah
but not not good enough not good enough
people are the people from that area
they don't want this you know this is a
nice country family town they want to go
back
to a time where murderers went to jail
yeah
so
it was a journey this trial it was a
journey Justice for Mallory Beach
Stephen Smith and Gloria yes
agreed are you ready for our next Story
another journey of the week yeah oh yeah
Selena versus Kylie Haley and the gals
honestly it seems like it seems like
everyone versus Haley right now that's
what the the vibe is
well according to the independent uh
Kylie Jenner lost half a million
Instagram followers this week amid the
drama
and Haley lost a [__] ton too muhammadin
she lose I think almost a million like
on Tick Tock and Instagram she went from
like 14 million to 13 million so you
can't tell exactly how many and on
Instagram like 50 to 49.
that is so crazy like
this doesn't exist no I know not a thing
except for people like talking about it
and making a thing and even I've seen
like some brands have been like were
team Selena it's like yeah on what what
are you talking about like and why are
you why are you a legitimate brand like
giving life to honestly
psychotic people on the internet yeah
like because let's backtrack like what
actually happened here a week ago both
Haley and Selena posted a tick tock that
really I genuinely believe had nothing
to do with Selena fans were quick to
point out like you know come to Selena's
defense you know it was just like
typical fan delusional Behavior pointing
out like why Kylie's video might be
about Selena and why Haley's videos
might be about Selena and what happened
was that Selena commented on the video
about Kylie saying no I love Kylie big
fan I don't think this is about me and
Kylie also commented like this is
reaching calm down so let's put that to
bed so Kylie both Kylie and Selena have
said Kylie didn't do anything yeah
Kylie's lost have a million followers
make it make sense
um then the Haley one with Kendall
and Justine Skye I believe
Haley Selena commented just kind of
encouraging that narrative like I don't
let this stuff get me down and then
other people being like Oh I always am
just sitting around feeling bad for
Selena Gomez like justice versus Selena
she commented on a bunch of them leaving
Hearts thank you so much really
encouraging this victimhood that she
sees herself in
um so with Haley Selena gave her fans
kind of room to run but with Kylie she
didn't and they still ran
there she still lost half a million
followers or more sorry yeah no half a
million
um I don't know what the [__] is going
on and now there every time I open my
page it's old videos of Haley popping up
and being like see Haley was a mean girl
this whole time and it's like yeah these
videos are not flattering she's
literally 16 in the videos like who
[__] cares they're taken out of
context like I'm just never gonna be see
a video of someone from five years ago
with no context and be like wow she's
really been a [__] this whole time like
I'm just because I'm normal I'm never
gonna do that
I saw the craziest most factual tweet
that just sums it up for me whoa it said
something like yeah mean girl Haley with
her lifelong friends sticking up for her
meanwhile Celine is beefing with her
Kidney donor
wow yeah no I also think now the
narrative has been like Haley has been
obsessed with Selena for seven years and
they're going back and finding any
instance where Selena and Haley did
something similar and there's definitely
a bunch of examples you could pull where
like they say something you know really
similar or Haley you know is doing
something similar and that's because
they are similar they're literally the
same age the same gender and live a very
similar lifestyle because they're both
extremely wealthy you know influencer
influential slash famous people yeah so
I don't think it's that crazy like they
both at one point in interview said I
wish people knew my heart like that's
how people talk
that's how people talk unfortunately
it's not like Selena said
and then Haley said
like they both just said something and
then people are like well you know
rare Beauty you know donates a
percentage of their proceeds to mental
health funds so does Road everyone does
like it's not these like crazy original
things that Selena is doing that Haley
is like copying her like that's just
it's what famous young women do it's
what they say they talk about mental
health like that's the world we live in
ever like people are reaching so hard
and that's not like
um and people are like are you team
Selena or team Haley I'm team nobody
because this doesn't exist I'm team
turdy I'm team getting my time back I
have to let you know though and what's
beautiful is that if you're not on Tick
Tock this does not exist aside from like
a few Publications writing it up because
they want those Jelena clicks
um I keep being shocked when I see an
update about this I'm like what what
happened not steal nothing still nothing
it's also worth noting that like the the
fandom who's supporting Selena is like
Haley's been a bully and a mean girl and
the [__] they're saying about Haley
right now so far exceeds the word
bullying it's [__] evil it's evil
it's so mean and you know what like they
are worse than what they're accusing
Haley of being and they're using videos
out of context from the last five years
to prove some sort of point that Haley
Bieber is some sort of evil wench it has
been this whole time
this is so moronic like I can't it's so
difficult to even talk about because
like nothing has happened I do think
though that like there is some
responsibility on Selena for encouraging
this and encouraging millions of people
to Bull like to bully
other two other girls
yeah
like I don't even think this has
anything to do with Kylie like and the
way I think what's happening to Kylie
and the loss of followers is just
honestly like
collateral but it's really about Haley
and Selena and I cannot believe we're
talking about this again like seriously
somebody shoot me especially after they
seem to have kids to meet up and they
took that picture and multiple pictures
and everything was fine like we need to
move on and it's best for Selena to move
on too like why does she want to keep
being dragged into this narrative with
her ex's wife yeah no it's not a good
look for her especially when she was you
know commenting on random people's tick
tocks then being like I'm taking a
social media break and then never took
the break you know what's also so funny
is that Selena's like best girlfriend
right now is like actually the Hollywood
mean girl
who
oh my God you're so right
yeah like that the way people think of
Haley like she's always been this mean
she's like a nepo baby privilege like
always been a [__] bully when I I
genuinely like I don't believe that she
is that but that's what people say about
Nicola and there's like stuff to back it
up and I I don't even think that Nicola
cares I saw her post a tick tock yep
video oh yeah yeah that one she's like
making this video it's like the sound
that's going off it's a song and it goes
you say that I'm really [__] boring
well that's rich coming from you
yeah like she doesn't care like I don't
even like for Haley like these labels
are really damaging I think also because
her brand is like yeah being you know
she's really like the American
sweetheart like
mental health whatever Nicholas just
like a nepo baby living her best life
like does whatever yeah whatever by the
way that's a really good point
that's a really good point and I just I
don't want this for Selena I feel like
Selena has made such strides in recent
years like she was she was really tied
to them and I don't think she wanted it
she was tied to them for so long and
it's like now she's you know after her
documentary she's releasing music rare
beauty is so powerful it's like the
biggest makeup brand in the world right
now and it's like I don't really know
why she would want to be dragged back
into this I feel like that was such a
bad time for her and she's made such
strides in moving past it yeah
I don't want this for her no
I'd love to see her Thrive outside of
this narrative
remember she was spotted with that guy
in Italy like we were moving past we
were moving past and now my entire
social media page is filled with old
edits of her and Justin riding bikes in
Venice Beach like why well now she's
fishing in Texas with her sister
so okay good good that's good that's
good
yeah anyways we'll see I can't say we'll
keep you posted no because as stated we
don't give a [__] oh and if something's
actually wildly unpopular which is so
shy crazy to me yeah can't relate I
really
um
I hope we don't have an update and the
only update we will give it's if
something actually happens yeah
yeah but Haley's posting like unbothered
Queen yesterday was Justin's birthday
happy 29th like she's moving on yeah
she's miss moving on people were
reaching so hard at the very beginning
of this like really making fake news
stories like Haley reposted somebody who
shared Road skin care and when you
repost someone's story if they have a
song on it the song that they had gets
reposted on yours so somebody had put up
a song um and I don't know the song but
there was a version there was a version
of that song that had come out with
Selena but the person who who shared the
story initially posted the original
version so Haley's story automatically
posted the non-selina version and
they're like look she's telling Selena
to calm down and not even using herself
chill the [__] out chill the [__] out
and then there's like all these edits
with millions of views being like
celebrities that have unfollowed Haley
Bieber Rihanna JLo it's not true people
are just making stuff up oh my God how
infuriating if you're for Haley yeah
how annoying no I'm gonna venture to say
that Haley Bieber is the victim in this
in this Saga and I'm completely unbiased
I love Selena love I love Haley I love
Kylie I Kylie's not even involved I
don't even want to say that he's not
even involved I have absolutely no bias
I am just looking at this Saga as a
rational adult human being
yeah
and if you don't agree with me maybe
you're not a rational adult no human
being right
because Theo is a rational adult ain't
that the truth and you know what he's
sleeping right now he says I'm bored by
this story this non-story that's what he
said
well you're ready for our next story if
it's the next story that's brought to
you by better help think you better help
for sponsoring today's episode of the
toast Getting to Know Yourself can be a
lifelong process especially because
we're always growing and changing I feel
like we're always talking about that
here at the toast like if you're not
growing if you're not hating who you
were years ago like you're not evolving
therapy is all about deepening your
self-awareness and understanding because
sometimes we don't know what we want or
what why we react to the way that we do
until we talk through things better help
connect you with licensed therapists who
can take you on that journey of
self-discovery from wherever you are so
if you're thinking of starting therapy
give better help a try better help is a
service that's done entirely online it's
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule just fill out a
brief questionnaire
then you'll get matched with a licensed
therapist and you can switch therapists
anytime for no additional charge what I
really like about betterhelp is that
it's done entirely online that's video
chat texting calling whatever you're
most comfortable doing because there's a
lot of parts of therapy that are like
deeply awkward and uncomfortable and I
feel like better help really helps ease
you into that by using whatever method
of communication you're most comfortable
with
um and they make it really easy to
switch therapists because I think a huge
part of therapy is kind of switching it
up in the beginning until you find
someone who you jive with because it's
such a personal thing so discover your
potential with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com toast today to get 10 off
your first month that's betterhelp
help.com slash toast betterhelp.com
toast thank you for sponsoring today's
episode and you guys start taking charge
of your mental health today yeah
our next story Matthew McConaughey's
wife Camila Alves was aboard the
turbulent jet that dropped 4 000 feet so
this week there was a Lufthansa flight
Lufthansa that was forced to land in
Virginia after it was hit by severe
turbulence the plane was bound for
Germany and then landed um at the Dulles
airport and it turns out that Camilla
Alves McConaughey was on the flight she
posted a clip from her seat to her 1
million Instagram followers displaying
the chaos on board and sharing her
experience following the emergency
landing she said on flight last night
plane dropped almost 4 000 feet seven
people went to the hospital everything
was flying everywhere to respect the
privacy of those around me that's all
I'm showing but the plane was a chaos
and the turbulence kept on coming at
least one passenger reported the plane
being struck by lightning during the
flight
they tweeted quote people who didn't
have their seat belts fast and got hurt
mostly because it came as a surprise
without Roosevelt sign on and lightning
hit the plane badly Camilla confirmed
her flight Wednesday was the same one
that was forced to land at Dulles
International Airport after hitting
severe turbulence over Tennessee
hospitalizing seven people oh my God
that is so crazy first of all that that
even happened yep and so crazy that
there was a star on board
yeah I'm glad everyone is the most part
okay yeah 4 000 feet
that's a drop by the way that's a drop
that doesn't it's you know a drop is
like a second but four thousand feet
you're dropping for a long time I don't
know exactly how long but that's [__]
scary it almost feels like probably
you're in free fall yeah so scary
imagine if you're not wearing your
seatbelt oh my God no and that's why
it's really so important like even
though it's annoying when you're sitting
just to be wearing your seatbelt always
yeah it's so true no I feel like I don't
even do that no me neither because like
the seat belt side's not on but there's
no time to get it on like it wasn't like
they were experiencing turbulence and
then there was just one bigger Spurt of
it than another like it came out of
nowhere I feel like there has to be more
to this than turbulence because
4 000 feet is like not
normal not normal that's not normal for
turbulence so they say that the one
person said it was struck by lightning
but they also framed it in a way that
made it seem like we don't know if this
person knows what they're talking about
yeah no it was one Rogue and like
Camilla didn't say our plane was struck
by lightning so and you know Lufthansa
didn't put out a statement saying it was
lightning but there clearly was
something more than just turbulence
right there was probably something wrong
where did they fly out of
uh
I'm not sure what does this have to do
with Tennessee
it was over Tennessee when the plane was
over Tennessee when this happened and so
they landed in Virginia and they were on
their way to Germany but cons oh maybe
they came out of Texas isn't that where
the McConaughey's live yeah
let me uh wow so crazy
yeah departed from Austin Texas I live a
little deductive reasoning that was good
investigative work thank you turdy Lou I
hope like everyone recovers from their
injuries this is so scary oh my God also
like mental injury like the trauma of
course 4 000 feet
um that's [__] frightening do you
remember that prank show yep I think
about this all the time I think about
this all the time that like pulled up
that pulls it's like a punked Vibes but
but it wasn't Punk punked and they
pulled a prank on um Paris Hilton they
were on a plane that like they pretended
to crash that was like the most [__]
up they pretended it was going down and
they like filmed her reaction like if I
I know Paris has a lot of trauma but to
me that's just as traumatic as like
everything else like no that's
legitimately thinking that you're dying
it's so funny I think about that oh and
then and it's not like oh I it was it
was a near miss it was like not only did
I think I was dying I was being played a
prank on used for energy
my level of trust for anything
would never be the same how does she
enter any space if it's like oh I was on
a private jet that was bugged by some
loser [__] pranksters yeah and I
trust anything no and like there's zero
possibility that it was fake because she
was freaky like the footage is so
real yeah no and I think she was upset
afterwards
I think she was like publicly upset
about the fact that they had done that
to her as she should yeah
yeah that's just what I was thinking
about well the good news is is that
the plane landed safely and everyone's
getting the help that that they need yes
true are you ready for our next story
yeah a little fashion Justice fashion
Justice fashion is being served and
Justice is being served while cardi B
does community service in Chanel she
says don't commit crimes the rapper was
ordered to complete 15 days of community
service as part of the plea deal she
received in September following a 2018
fight at a strip club and this week she
offered her Twitter fans an update on
how giving back is going for her she
shared snaps of her unsurprisingly
upscale outfits before reporting for
Duty several days in a row so she
tweeted Samara selfies of her looks for
community service saying day whatever
the [__] up community service obey the
law I just want to say like the looks
are so cute she posted this one pink
Chanel bag that's so funny I have to get
this bag she is seriously hysterical
she's so funny and of course like you
shouldn't you know break the law but
she's using it to spread a good message
obey the law no she just need to spread
a good message look there are
consequences yep for your actions and
I'm here paying the price like let me be
a lesson I think this is a a great
moment for cardi B and she's being funny
yeah oh and she's being funny and she's
being fashionable and she's like you
know she's doing the work yeah she's
doing her time she did the crime she's
doing the time
it's overall a pretty decent message and
now I have to find the Chanel bag and
she's inspired me she's inspiring others
she's inspiring others you'd love to see
something good come out of something bad
and it's like even if you're on a
community service like
get dressed up yeah for the community
yeah I mean where you know uh sensible
function sensible functional outfits but
have some style add a little glamor to
that Community I love it I love it
that's a community service
hundred percent
so
good work hard to be good work cardi B
our fifth and final story for our fifth
and final episode of the week
uh a little new couple news Chase Stokes
and Kelsey ballerini are smooching It Up
in a New York City date night amid her
divorce drama case Chase Stokes and
Kelsey ballerini are making public
appearances as a couple now and they're
all smiles about it they hit up the
Rangers game on Thursday night at
Madison Square Garden and during their
time in the stands Chase grabbed her by
the chin for her kiss real romantic
stuff their couple name is Chelsea
yeah I was already starting to complete
their names I'm like they've been
together for two weeks I was talking
about them literally two days ago and I
said Chelsea and case
yeah that's what I you heard me Mom
that's what I where I was going yeah
that it works it works
um I'm so excited for SNL actually I'm
gonna really try and stay up and watch
it I'm not gonna try and stay up because
I know thyself I will be watching on
Sunday and I'm really excited and I like
that reel that they did like Kelsey to
set and they both came out but did you
see the
um you know how they do the promos and
they were all really bad yeah who was
Heidi Gardner was that was next to
Travis and they were like I'm Travis
Kelsey goes you guys know what Kelsey
ballerini and then like Heidi Garden
little skit it's a little skit they do a
few of them and then we're all like
Dreadful no and like get let Kelsey get
involved like she said they're cute
it was
really painful and really scary for what
might be to come I know it's always
scary when you see something from SNL
that's like really not funny and it puts
into perspective how like these are
supposed to be the greatest comedic
minds of our time and like this is the
best they could come up with yeah
no no I'm still going to be optimistic
plus uh TMZ reported that Jason has been
called to the stage it's unclear what
his role oh will be especially since he
just had a baby girl but they obviously
want him like front row engaging in the
sketches and I think the rest of the fam
will be there too obviously Jason called
to Stage Jason has been called to Stage
that's so good to know I totally forgot
he has to be there like we and it's like
obviously we love him but the Eagles
fans like love him like he is like a
yeah a United State area Legend he
really is and I think everybody wants to
see him up there 100 I totally forgot
but I'm so glad that it I figured he
would be the whole family is going to
get involved
um
but what was I going to say oh let's do
predictions for what we think Kelsey's
gonna sing I've I've been watching a lot
of her footage because she was on a mini
tour this last week in the UK and she's
saying Penthouse and I do think she's
going to sing Penthouse no yeah it's not
even my favorite one okay this is a a
prediction of both what I want her to
sing and what I think she'll sing so I'm
combining the two because I I still
think she's gonna do one like acoustic
rolling up the welcome mat moment and
one fun pop moment I hope so I really
really think so because she's from
subject to change yeah so like heart
first yeah I mean she's literally about
to embark on another huge leg of the
heart first tour I think she'll start
with heart first
and then she'll strip it down my hope is
that she sings mountain with a view me
too because that's my favorite song but
then you've told me that Blindside it is
pretty viral
uh oh
miss me again love me again leave me
again yeah I think that that's a like
she literally sings it strip down on the
music video
it's gonna be one of those it's gonna be
one from rolling up the welcome mat one
from subject to change
huge marketing opportunity for her and
she is you know doing this tour I would
I could see a world in which she does
two songs from the EP but I I do think
one from Hartford I think you're right I
think one from heart first I would love
if she did subject to change but like
that wasn't a single I should probably
do
um
I don't know the little things maybe
what is her most recent single from her
from subject to change that's a good
question let me tell you really quick I
got it
subject to change is so good like
it's 7 A.M and I'm on a mountain with a
view uh I'm the only one how do you know
what's a single except for two uh
see discography
singles if you go down I'm going down
too I love that song
but our little things is a single what I
have is a single love is a Cowboy is a
single and heart versus a single I think
it's gonna be the little things
okay I'll have to listen to it I don't
think it'll be if you go down it's a
little too um Niche country like yeah
and and it's like she's has so much
range and it's like a yeah a little
Dilly Dilly of a song okay my official
my official guess is the little things
and penthouse
okay my official hopeful guess is
subject to Heart first
and
mountain with a v wait you know what
let's go to what's the most played one
from oh that's a good question from the
EP from the EP mountain with the view is
at 5.9 million blindsided is 4.7 but
also the EP starts with mountains so
like people click that first but it's
not like it's
that other one what about you keep
saying Penthouse it doesn't come up on
top five so then I can't see listens oh
that's bizarre all right I guess we'll
just have to wait and see
yeah or leave me again man with you and
leave me again are my hopeful guesses
okay
um
or both a little right like it'll be
little things and mountain with a view
yeah yeah I mean I love mountain with
the video I would love if we're both
right
I would love that I think we're all
I think we're better than all right I
think we're fabulous totally especially
now that it's officially the weekend I
know what are your hopes and wishes and
dreams for the weekend before we let
everyone go
oh
um fun times memories made
restfulness achieved yeah
restorativeness
laughter and joy those are mine that's
beautiful Turtle
who wants to thank you all for listening
to the toast the Monday Morning Show
where we deliver the fast five stories
that you need to know everybody through
Friday on YouTube so if you're watching
this on YouTube please don't forget to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available podcasting we're
podcasting we found Spotify iTunes
Central Public Radio I already cast box
all the places podcast episode 5 story
about a beautiful standing and wicked
little talented we are hope you guys
have any
Friday we will see you on Monday have a
blessed weekend a little bit of an
update for next week as we have a short
week next week we have episodes Monday
Tuesday Wednesday because Wednesday
night I am headed to Portugal for Brian
Kelly's 40th birthday so I am taking two
days off please don't kill me I just
really want to go I'll be making the
most of them so I'm excited I get back
really late Sunday night but I am coming
in Monday morning so I'm doing it as
best as I can missing the least amount
of episodes Thursday and Friday okay
understood Turtle love you guys have an
amazing weekend stay lit and stay
wickedly talented
love you bye